college professors you can watch the
classes here every saturday evening at 8
p.m and midnight eastern
next holy cross professor edward
o'donnell talks about the prejudice many
immigrants faced in the 19th century
with regard to religion customs and
social status professor o'donnell says
this often led to fights over what would
be taught in public schools questions
about the loyalty for catholic
politicians and job postings stating
such things as no irish need apply
this class is about an hour and 10
minutes
so welcome to the
latest chapter of the irish american
experience as you know today we'll be
talking about nativism the
anti-immigrant movement that explodes in
the mid 19th century focused on pretty
much all immigrants but
uh really focusing on the irish they're
the as we know the the biggest group the
most identifiable group they're also in
the crowded cities and so forth so they
stand out and they generate an enormous
um
opposition
so before we we get into that um let's
let's back up a little bit because we're
not just simply talking about um the
irish today because
the nativist response that the irish
generate
actually existed before the irish got
here you can actually find early
versions of it in the 18th century
and you also find echoes of it since
that time so it actually this question
about anti-immigrant sentiment
speaks to the larger american experience
it's a kind of phenomenon that we pride
ourselves on being a nation of
immigrants we are a nation of immigrants
but we are also a nation that is always
questioning that that tradition so let's
start now you know looking at things in
2014 right what do americans think about
immigration
well if you go to ellis island you'll
see this image here which is an american
flag uh very large about 20 feet long 10
feet high and if you stand on one end of
it's got i don't know kind of a hologram
effect if you stand over uh to the right
side you just see this big flag and then
if you walk towards where i'm standing
the image changes and you can start to
see all these little faces representing
different ethnic and racial groups so
ellis island's probably a great example
of how much americans love immigration
and this may seem strange given the
politics today the headlines today but
americans millions of americans
i would venture say probably most
americans today in the 21st century
absolutely love
immigration
so as strange as that may sound hold
that thought but we know from headlines
from uh politics from debates in
congress and so forth that americans
also hate immigration
and the thing is we've always hated it
and there's there's a we'll get to the
explaining how that's possible to love
and hate something at the same time and
we're not saying that you know half of
americans love it and half of them hate
it it's that millions of americans at
the same
time love it and hate it
and there's a good reason for that and
it's been the same reason for for a long
long time
two kinds of immigration this is one way
to look at it so
who wants a venture of guests like how
is it possible for somebody you know
maybe even if you go back to that
earlier image you know this this woman
standing there holding the flag saying
america has been invaded how would
somebody like that um
express love for immigration what kind
of immigration would she like anyway
that she'd like uh
she'd like like the old style of
immigration not like old but like
immigration in the past probably when
like her ancestors most likely came over
right so the key word is what past past
past immigration immigration from a
generation or two or three or four ago
always
uh seems pleasing it always seems um to
be
a welcome thing a positive thing a
contributing thing uh to the greater
good of the united states and that and
what kind of immigration uh do you
imagine uh we that americans hate even
some of the same people like when they
when people push back against
immigration denounce immigration whether
illegal or legal what's the what kind do
they
do they dislike
jack what's the likely
someone who likes past immigration
has actually very strong feelings about
it but
uh
well i guess obviously then they would
just be opposed to the new immigration
illegal immigration stuff like that yeah
even illegal immigration some people are
upset about how many people are actually
coming to this country legally so it has
to do with timing and what we basically
have done as a society generations and
even centuries uh over time we have
compartmentalized our understanding of
immigration we tend to think of it in
very very positive terms in you know its
museum setting which is why millions of
people go to the statue of liberty and
to ellis island and do their genealogy
and millions of americans will proudly
tell you about when their grandfather
came over from greece or from ireland or
wherever and how became part of the
great american dream
but when it's happening around us
whether it's us in 2014 us in 1944 us in
1894 or 1844 uh it seems alarming it
seems seems quite alien and quite
dangerous and so that's the kind of
dynamic we're going to be looking at
here today that where these ideas of uh
uh of two ways of thinking about
immigration and the way
a variation on this two kinds of
immigration is to think about
uh
the positive side of immigration the way
we think about it in positive terms and
it's something i call like i call the
the multicultural ideal
and that is throughout our you know our
in our especially in the 20th 21st
century we've developed this kind of
language of diversity this language of
tolerance this language of
multiculturalism where we kind of the
kind of words we use to express why it's
a good thing and this has great uh you
know historical depth to it you go back
to the late in this case late 18th
century
hector st john de kreviker wrote a
series of small essays about america as
america was being born
and he's really one of the first guys to
write down
what this thing is this america that's
that's being born and one of his most
famous observations and lines is that he
said here individuals of all nations are
melted into a new race of men whose
labors and posterity will one day cause
great changes in the world so he's
saying a america's destined for
greatness and b one of the key factors
is that it it it has this melting pot
effect taking people and ideas and
traditions and melding them into a new
race of people so that's not a new idea
way back in the colonial period uh we
had people talking on those terms but we
also had people like benjamin franklin
who normally we cite as
you know one of the most open-minded
people in the in america in the world
you know he's one of the great examples
of the enlightenment he's into science
and into public service and literature
and he's also a great entrepreneur
but he is not above
having that kind of uh
negative reaction to immigration as it's
happening so in the mid 1800s 1700s
experience a big influx of german
immigrants and they're settling mostly
in areas that's now called germantown
and so franklin just goes off on them
and says and you have to he refers to
them as palatine boars which you'll just
have to trust me as a really nasty thing
to say about germans but he says why are
we doing this why do we let these people
come here why should the palatine boars
be suffered to swarm into our
settlements and by hurting together
establish their language and manners to
the exclusion of ours
why should pennsylvania founded by the
english become a colony of aliens who
will shortly be so numerous as to
germanize us instead of our anglifying
them and will never adopt our language
or customs any more than they can
acquire our complexion
so in 1753 we have a vivid you know
expression of of classic nativism where
the he's making the case they're not
going to blend in they're going to bring
alien ways and cause lots of trouble
and this may sound familiar and uh to to
prove the point of how timeless those
words are if we just take what franklin
just said in 1753 and change six words
right we'll set it in a modern context
we'll talk about mexican immigration
in california so this is what franklin
said in 1753 but if we just swap out
some modern words it reads like this why
should mexicans be suffered to swarm
into our settlements and by hurting
together establish their language and
culture to the exclusion of ours
why should california founded by
americans become a colony of aliens who
will sure shortly be so numerous as to
hispanicize us instead of our
americanizing them and we'll never adopt
our language and customs any more than
they can acquire our complexion so it's
it's timeless timeless uh expressions
and they go they have deep deep
historical roots
all right does anybody have any
questions
all right so why do we think this way
let's jump into this but before we do um
let's let's remind ourselves about where
we are historically right this is we're
about almost halfway through our
semester uh
looking at the experience of
irish-american immigration and we're
sort of situated in the middle 19th
century we've already talked about the
famine migration and some of the
struggles of those immigrants
economically socially politically in our
previous class
and that's part of the old immigration
really the big explosion of immigration
that took place
in the
first two thirds of the 19th century
and it's 8 million immigrants they
mostly come from northern and western
europe
and so you're talking about the irish
germans english scandinavians and i
attack in the chinese who obviously
don't come from
northern and western europe but they
come to california in this in this time
period they're very small numbers but
they're a distinct group and they too
will generate their own nativist uh
response on the west coast
and then around 1880 a new flow a much
larger flow uh you can see the numbers
eight million versus 20 million and the
flow now predominantly starts to come
from eastern and southern europe you
still have
irish immigrants you still have german
and english but their proportional
numbers are are quite small
so it's right in the middle of this old
immigration that the nativist response
just explodes
and it turns out turns into more than
just a lot of anger it actually turns
into a full-blown uh political movement
all right so what is this uh this
nativist tradition well um let's talk
about politically and historically what
happens in the mid 19th century first
and then what we're going to do is break
down nativism into its uh component
parts
so here's a classic emblem of the of the
know nothing party or the american party
is its formal name their nickname were
the was the know
and it's not entirely clear why they
were called to know nothings except that
uh the the lore is that they were a
secret society mid 19th century america
loved its secret societies and you know
the masons and so forth and part of the
way they created an allure about
themselves is that they wouldn't tell
people about the organization so if
somebody walked up to a know-nothing or
a member of the american party and said
tell me about that that group you're
with he'd say i know nothing right and
that was just only to heighten the guys
uh heighten his interest so they're
known as the know nothings and they're
they're early versions of it the 1830s
and 1840s but it becomes a full-blown
political movement uh in the mid-19th
century
particularly in 1854 and 1855
and
uh the american party it's important to
point out what what's happening
in 1854 is that the whig party remember
there's the whig party and the
democratic party the weak party is
collapsing it's disintegrating over the
issue of slavery so we are in this
strange period 1854 55 where we actually
have one main party and then a whole
bunch of splinter parties that are
trying to sort themselves out and
you know creating a viable second party
and a lot of americans believe that the
american party was the next big party
the replacement for the whigs turned out
there's another movement out there
that's uh more concerned about slavery
and that's the republican party and
that's the one that's going to triumph
but for here it certainly looks like the
american party and just take a look at
these statistics
in 1854
the american party wins control of the
state governments of delaware
pennsylvania and massachusetts
and in massachusetts it's it's a
complete sweep they take control of both
houses of the state legislature the
lieutenant governor the the governor and
hundreds of other uh high offices and
and positions
of power so it's a complete takeover um
and then the next year maryland kentucky
also come under american party control
so a lot of people again sort of
political forecasters if there were such
things in those days would be saying the
american party seems to be the one
that's getting traction this
anti-immigration movement seems to be
the one that's that's going to coalesce
into a a viable second party
a couple more stats they uh also had
really strong finishes and took you know
created became quite powerful not quite
dominant in states like new york and
california um and then in congress
75 uh congressmen were elected with
either explicit american party
credentials or they had the backing
of the american party uh so they were
there's a lot of political influence
both locally uh and at the state level
and also even in the halls of congress
all right
anybody have any questions
okay so let's let's uh let's look at
this what were the nativists afraid of
uh they're afraid of a lot of things and
it does change over time so that in
different time periods certain things
you know the order of priority or the
order of things that people are worried
about uh tends to change
but in 1850 the mid-19th century period
when the know-nothings emerge religion
is absolutely positively
the number one issue specifically
catholicism
so one of the readings that i had to do
uh was by samuel f b morse
uh who to most americans almost all
americans can name who have a sense of
history can name the one thing that
morris is famous for this is the morse
right he's the depending on how you
define inventor he's the inventor of the
telegraph he's certainly the inventor of
the telegraph that becomes the standard
and really revolutionizes communication
so that's a pretty big
uh contribution to history he's also
well known as an artist uh he's one of
america's better known early
19th century artists but he has a third
feather in his cap uh in terms of being
well known and making an imprint on his
society and that is he's a leading voice
of anti-catholic alarmism he's basically
if you look just at the title of his
1835 publication the foreign conspiracy
against the liberties of the united
states pretty explicit
so you had to do that reading last night
uh what let's let's ask
a few questions here who can tell me
some of the ideas some of the
accusations he's making alex um
pretty much that the catholics were
following me the rule the pope and uh
the priest would pretty much command him
command them
and uh
shoot well that's let's get us started
right there right so the whole idea is
that unlike true born americans who are
individuals who are free thinkers who
are beholden to no one but themselves uh
the mod the idea that morse is conveying
is that catholics are by nature
authoritarian and believe in
authoritarian structure and so that the
hierarchy of the church reflects this
kind of un-american unrepublican uh
undemocratic way of thinking and
operating so that's kind of a mark
against somebody saying it's even worse
it's not just that they have this kind
of hierarchical way of thinking um
what's the conspiracy
i think he sees a really big connection
between the catholic church and european
influence so he sees catholics in
america is still beholden to the pope
and then with that political influence
in uh europe
right so that and notice he's saying the
the foreign conspiracy so
uh
to most non-catholics particularly those
who are concerned about the rise of
catholicism in in the united states are
saying catholicism by its nature
disqualifies you
as a
true republican citizen because
not only are do you believe in this kind
of hierarchical way of operating society
but you also according to their
understanding of things oh complete
loyalty to a foreign king a foreign
power in this case the pope and the pope
was a civil leader right he they they
see him as a king um kind of a different
sort of a king but they depict him in
royal terms monarchical terms which is
the counter-opposite of americans
political understanding of themselves
so
what else what are some of the anybody
want to just tell me a phrase or
something that that stood out from his
uh
is that um
at the very end like the last paragraph
he
calls uh catholics like the enemy uh he
says the enemy is awake and then he
basically says that their whole goal is
to
basically like rid the world of liberty
um not just america but like the whole
entire world right so he says
protestantism is tied to liberty
republican liberty they're inseparable
and catholicism is tied to what
good mid 19th century word
the d word what's the despotism right
despotism that it's that it's
essentially a religion of tyranny of
despotism of uh squelching of freedom
freedom of conscience and so forth so
he's saying this is
you know hey americans as you look
around and see all these poor seemingly
hopeless helpless irish coming into our
cities don't be fooled
this is part of an advanced army of the
pope who is hates liberty hates
republicanism and it has designs to
destroy it as soon as he can as soon as
he gets enough bodies on the ground and
then they have leaders priests and the
priests have leaders bishops and the
bishops have leaders archbishops and the
archbishops have leaders cardinals and
this is a command structure that is
going to over attempt to overthrow the
republic now this may sound just crazy
you know conspiracy theory uh gone awry
but it made a lot of sense to people in
that period
um does anybody
have a way uh or see a connection
between this kind of conspiracy mania in
a different period in american history
yeah it's it's amazing like i just
swapped out those words of franklin and
put in mexican and california instead
you could take some of what morse wrote
and instead of catholic put in the word
communist and soviet russia and it works
just the same way hey americans are
slumbering while you know your liberties
are about to be under overtaken by these
hundreds of spies and sympathizers in
america that was the message of mccarthy
in the 1940s and 1950s
so
conspiracy theories
are often have you know tremendous
amount of similarity to them okay so
morse writes us he's not alone there's a
huge amount of anti-catholic literature
published in america at this time it's
the biggest you know if you go into a
barnes and noble today
there's the automotive section the
self-help section and the uh
spirituality section and so forth and a
biography in history if there was such a
thing as a barnes noble in 1835 a big
section would be you know the pope is
coming to get us
uh people conspiracy literature hundreds
of books and pamphlets published and
images so you all have uh a copy of this
image in front of you or between you um
take a moment to look at it and see the
connections this is a visual
representation
from a book a different book published
at roughly the same time period
that shows many of the same many of the
messages many of the ideas and
accusations that
morse was making uh but here in visual
form so
what do you notice about the details
what are some of the
uh the pope's like on the throne yeah so
you couldn't look any more royal right
if we didn't know any context here we'd
say this is some sort of european king
so he's sitting on the throne he's got a
couple of you know lackeys on either
side of him
great big crown and that's to emphasize
remember americans in the 19th century
are
when they think about what they are they
also think about what they aren't they
are republicans and democrats with small
r and small d they believe in liberty
and the opposite of that is monarchy and
aristocracy and so forth so this is a
very alarming image and what's the pope
what's the action of the eddie what's
the action in the in the image or
the direction of the image
uh it's towards the town towards the
american town yeah so it's a split
screen even though it's a little bit
hard to tell it's you know he's in rome
you can see the basilica on the on
beyond behind him and he's pointing sort
of across towards america towards the uh
across the atlantic ocean which we don't
see towards a schoolhouse
and the message and so
schoolhouses we'll see in a few moments
that becomes the flashpoint of this
anti-catholic mania one of the flash
points um
so anything else any other
it also looks like he's standing on the
bible yeah and then a lot of the things
we've read they talked about how the
pope just didn't want anything to do
with the bible and that looks like it's
a pretty significant thing yeah he's got
his foot on the bible which you know is
a is an important detail because and
it's more of the religious side of the
argument which is that you know by now
it's it's 1855 when this image was first
published and the the point that people
would make is that uh protestants
believe in individualism and individual
reading and interpretation of the bible
and so forth if you know your
reformation history and catholics again
have that authoritarian idea that only
the pope and only the bishops and only
the priests can tell you can read only
certain parts of the bible to you and
tell you what it means
and that's
that's obviously an exaggerated image
that the pope is anti-bible right um
well we'll talk about public schools in
just a moment
this now you can see uh where this comes
from the title of this
book is called the papal conspiracy
exposed and protestantism vindicated by
edward beecher and the
title of the image itself is potpourry
undermining free schools
the public school system is being
invented in the united states in this
time period and people quickly start to
see it as kind of a key part of
democracy and and a republic and when
the big debate ensues in this period
about which bible not whether to read
the bible
nobody disagreed on that it was what
bible catholic bible or protestant bible
then
the fur began to fly
another incident this is in not far from
we are where we are in massachusetts
in 1834 a convent the ursuline convent
was burned to the ground by an angry mob
that showed up in august of 1834 there
were wild rumors that the nuns had
kidnapped a local protestant girl and
were holding her against her will
forcing her to become a catholic nun and
the mob showed up they were kind of
egged on by preachers and they burned uh
the convict luckily nobody uh was hurt
but it stands as kind of a vivid symbol
of uh the conspiracy
the belief in the conspiracy and the uh
the fear that people had for catholicism
um now a little bit more detail about
this uh pope is coming to get us
literature that we were talking about uh
just in this 40-year period 1820 to 1860
210 books i mean you can read the
numbers there huge output of
anti-catholic catholic conspiracy
literature uh one right after the other
i mean this stuff was more popular than
anti-slavery or pro-slavery literature
which was the other great cultural
debate uh in the mid-19th century
and the one the best-selling book of all
in fact it only gets dethroned as the
best-selling book in 1852 with uncle
tom's cabin is the one where this image
is drawn from the awful disclosures of
mariah monk
is published in 1836 and it purported to
tell the story it was later exposed to
be a fraud but it purported to tell the
story of a young
teenage girl who uh joined a catholic
convent she was a protestant living in
canada but she somehow became you know
became friendly with the nuns decided to
enter the convent and as soon as the
doors were shut she found out the real
story the you know the what was really
happening behind those walls and most of
it involved sexual impropriety priests
taking advantage of nuns uh among other
things and it fed this so there's a
there's a kind of a
fear that there's actually an army of
catholics about to overthrow the
republic there's also this fear that the
morally speaking uh they they pose a
great threat to the republic
and that was actually why this kind of
fear of convince why the convent was
burned
which we talked about a moment ago so
mariah amongst book becomes a huge
bestseller she actually goes on a book
tour and telling these people her tale
of woe
the baby she's holding is the baby she
was eventually became pregnant according
to her story from an irish priest and uh
fled the convent because they were going
to kill her baby to hide the evidence
and she then went on book tour and you
know sold thousands and thousands of
books she was later exposed as a fraud
she actually ended up dying dying in
poverty the the people that the the
anti-catholic
activists that that sponsored her um got
all the money and we know this because
they all suit each other and there's a
whole court record explaining who wrote
who actually wrote the book and
and so forth
all right you get the picture um now we
mentioned on that earlier image that the
free school that the american school was
one of the key flash points so what do
americans think about schools uh as
they're becoming these key institutions
in this emerging democracy if you just
read the these words here this is from
the minnesota chronicle and register in
1850 and basically makes the case that
in you put anything you want into a
public school and out of it comes a
republican citizen right public schools
take the child of the exile of hungary
the half-starved immigrant from the
emerald isle there's the irish and the
hardy norwegian and places on the same
bench with the offspring of those whose
ancestors bones bleached upon the fields
of lexington you know long-standing uh
generations of americans as the child of
the foreigner plays with a school fellow
he learns to whistle yankee doodle and
see seeing hale colombia and before he
leaves the school desk for the plow the
anvil or the trowel he is as sturdy a
little republican as can be found in the
land so americans has a very very
positive feeling about this emerging
public school system and then along come
this
this large immigrant group mostly irish
catholics who say
we don't want to send our kids to the
public schools we can't because they're
immoral
and they threaten the souls and threaten
the well-being of our kids now here's
archbishop hughes he becomes the
really the most prominent catholic
leader in the mid-19th century and he
says a brief experience of the public
school system in the city of new york
convinced us that we could not discharge
our conscientious duty to our offspring
if we allowed them to be brought up
under the influence of irreligious
principles upon which these schools are
conducted and so hughes is throwing down
the you know the religious cultural
gauntlet and saying we're going to build
our own parochial school system at a
cost of millions of dollars to save our
souls it's a real kind of rejection of
uh
a key institution in america in american
life uh and furthermore what he doesn't
say here is that those who still go to
public school we're gonna fight for
their right to read catholic bibles not
protestant bibles
so this this public school stuff really
it's not just an intellectual argument
in philadelphia in the in the spring of
18 of 1844 the city of philadelphia
explodes in religious sectarian rioting
known as the bible riots because they're
arguing about which bible is going to be
used uh in the public school and these
are real riots they're going for days 20
people are killed three churches are
burned uh you know blood running in the
streets over this issue of catholic or
protestant bibles uh for public schools
all right and you can still see evidence
of this in new york uh most people know
fifth uh the cathedral st patrick's
which is on fifth avenue right in the
middle of midtown but its earlier
version is way down in what's now
chinatown this is the old saint
patrick's cathedral and you notice
something about it it has this very high
wall around it this is a 10 foot high
wall all the way around the property and
that was not there originally this
church was built in 1814 uh there was no
wall it was open but they've built the
wall in the 1840s because they were
afraid the church is going to be
destroyed because mobs constantly
rumored and threatened uh to do so and
you can see this is a side shot from the
sidewalk with people walking to give you
an idea of it's really a fortified
cathedral big thick walls three feet
thick at the base
all right here's a show a couple more
images before we move on to a different
uh
aspect of nativism thomas nast we'll see
a number of his images he's the great
cartoonist of the late 19th century
cartooning everything and involving
politics but he has this particular
focus on the threat of the catholic
church and this is in the 1870s so this
gives you an idea of how this this plays
out over uh over decades these are not
alligators hitting the beaches of
america these are irish bishops if you
turn your head sideways you can see
these are irish bishops hitting the
beaches and there's a school master
protecting the school children of
america from the from foreign catholic
influence
and then just to give you a quick look
forward this is 1928. this is you know
we're well into the 20th century and al
smith who we'll talk about in a
subsequent uh lecture
is running for president he's the first
irish catholic to be nominated by a
major parties the democratic party um
and he just gets gets uh hammered uh by
the republicans and also by the ku klux
klan and other uh nativist anti-catholic
groups and here it shows him you know
conforming to that idea he's a he bows
before a foreign king this case kisses
the the ring of the pope could you vote
for him he wants us to be you know place
him in the white house the answer is
obvious you can't have a catholic sit in
the white house and it's 32 years later
when john f kennedy runs and he too has
to it's everything is diminished quite a
bit then but he still has to answer that
question can you be a catholic and a
political independent political leader
in the united states and we also know if
you look across the country today more
than two dozen states have passed
anti-sharia law
statutes
because people are
imagining that there's this conspiracy
sharia by stealth this idea that sharia
law muslim law is creeping into our
political system and that they're
heading it off at the past by passing
these resolutions
i think it's over 30 states now uh have
done so in just a few just recent times
so this religion and nativism go hand in
hand all right another dimension
nativism and
non-assimilation or i should say
perceived non assimilation it's always
in the eye of the beholder
and this is what new york city looked
like in 1865 you can see there's two
predominant
ethnic enclaves we've seen this map
before the orange represents little
germany or klein deutschland that's the
concentrated area of germans and the
three green wards there represent the
area where the irish are concentrated
and you know today we go to little
italy's and chinatowns and american
cities it's a place to try ethnic food
and all nobody's pretty pleased about
this uh this is seen as a a
willful effort not to blend in in fact
it conforms exactly to what ben franklin
was saying you know they're the crowding
together hurting together to use his
phrase and refusing to assimilate
they're going to try to germanize or
irish eyes us
rather than us americanize them
and you can see
you know this is a kind of a typical
comment from this period there are
portions of new york where the
population is as thoroughly irish as in
dublin or cork and this is not an amused
statement this is an alarmed statement
about people not blending in all right
and this is a map of boston you can see
that with the dots all clustered
together there at the bottom of the
image and off on to the right those are
the irish neighborhoods they're bunched
together it most people don't look at
that sociologically and economically and
say oh that's the worst housing that's
the one place that people will let them
live they say these people are choosing
to crunch together choosing to not um
assimilate
and and one of our readings from last
night
touches on this on this issue from 1860
so uh i should have actually given you a
little bit of background on that but in
1860 the united states is going to
welcome the prince of wales it's going
to be a big visit
pump and circumstance all wherever he uh
wherever he goes and part of the
ceremonies that have a great big parade
uh for this you know all the different
militias are going to march and various
things are going to give the the prince
a great big welcome and michael corcoran
who's an irish nationalist one of these
guys has been driven out of ireland in a
chapter we'll talk about in a couple of
classes and he says he's the head of the
irish brigade this irish regiment and he
says we're not marching for that guy
he's the you know he's the heir to the
crown of the the crown that oppresses
ireland no we're not going to march in
his honor we can't do it and he gets
brought up when he gets court-martialed
uh eventually and the only thing that
saves him is the civil war breaks out so
what's in the harper's weekly uh
editorial
about our our irish soldiers what's the
what's their
interpretation what do they say this
tells us about the irish
from what i could tell it sort of seemed
like they were calling the irish
ungrateful they kept going on about how
they um
the americans have given them land
pretty cheap land and they've been
they've been good to them they've
allowed them to practice their
catholicism
even though we don't want to we're going
to let we've been good we've been
tolerant right so they're making it seem
like they've been very tolerant to them
and painting the irish just to be um
these insubordinate um
just people that they don't want in
their country right disloyal i mean
really sort of like we've given you all
this you don't deserve it there's a part
there where it rattles off you're
filling our jails you're filling our
hospitals you're jacking up our taxes
you're corrupting our democracy and we
still let you stay
and yet you pull this incredibly
embarrassing act of essentially treason
um we can't trust you you're you're bad
at you're you're not going to be we if
this tells us you're probably not ever
going to be
good americans just because um either
it's your temperament or your religion
or whatever whatever it may be
so it really angered
um
harp the editors at harper's and this
was a kind of one of those flash points
where people kind of put their cards
on the table and you can see in this
image
a pretty uh vivid example of how the
irish are perceived so the the message
of this is you see lady liberty and
she's stirring the pot of of immigrants
um and you can see all different kinds
of ethnic groups represented but notice
the one who's
he's eventually going to get in there
that's the implication uh he's
eventually going to get into the soup
but he's going to probably have to be
whacked over the head right he's got his
irish flag he's got his his knife and
he's exhibiting that kind of anger and
and riotousness that that people
associate with the irish um
it's it's not no coincidence that he's
the one standing on the lip of the of
the pot
all right so another dimension of
nativism um is just this perception it's
much more it's more vague but it's
related to this idea of of clustering
together but it's this idea that they're
taking over
uh and you sometimes hear this you know
they were in in years past people would
talk about that the cubans are taking
over miami or what have you this is this
is an earlier version of that when the
irish came in such enormous numbers and
we've talked about some of those numbers
where
they go from being a small percentage of
new york and boston and philadelphia to
becoming you know 30 40 50
if you include their american-born
children
50 percent of the population
and here's a vivid cartoon from the
1860s
the great fear of the period
uncle sam may be swallowed by foreigners
and so this is actually looking from
canada right so you've got the irish on
the east coast uh and the chinese
immigrant on the west coast and they are
literally devouring uh uncle sam in kind
of a grotesque uh you know horror film
way this is actually the first panel
this is the multi-panel cartoon in the
end the [ __ ] swallows the ir the
irishman which gives you an idea that if
people had to choose who they thought
was the most dangerous and the most
unassimilable they would choose the
chinese but um the irish are right
behind them all right so we can see in
this image you know the the the radica
the
rapid and and uh
really shocking growth of the irish
population in this mid 19th century
period
uh
largely due to the famine but we also
know that before the famine there were
already 45 000 uh irish living in new
york city so
it's a uh
and this does not include the the
their american born children so it's
just it's 25 28
of people born in ireland so if you
throw in their kids you're talking 40 or
50
uh of the population
all right and don't forget that one
thing that's in that statistic is that
these aren't just irish people they're
also mostly irish catholics so there's
sort of a double uh set of fear there
and i just threw this one this image in
two to sort of show you the connections
with other uh groups this is from 1882
and it's a it's you can see the caption
on the bottom the day the dream of the
jews realized and the cartoon is here in
1882 is showing new york city completely
taken over by uh jewish immigrants and
they're taking down look on the
right-hand side the science is john
smith dry goods you know nice good
american-born name john smith that's
coming down and moses eckstein and son
are is is being placed up there uh the
the new york herald is now the new
jerusalem herald and you can see you
know
sort of stereotypical characteristics of
jewish uh peoples kind of lording
themselves over the city
that they've just begun to come to and
the funny thing about this image is that
it's 1882 and people are the cartoonist
is worried they're too many jews in new
york and it's just at this moment that
the real great way the great wave uh of
the next 40 years is going to unfold
when new york becomes very identified
with the jewish population uh because a
third of the jews in the world primarily
from eastern europe are going to come to
the united states so this guy's having a
he's freaking out so to speak in 1882
and he has no idea what's about what's
about to hit uh the american shores
all right
now another one especially with the
irish nativism and poverty this idea now
we think about this this is not just a
matter of of of
thinking that america that immigrants
are you know raising our poverty
statistics
it's not just a matter of um of that
it's a it has to do with our political
culture and our sense of ourselves right
america what do americans think when
they think about themselves and their
country and the republic and so forth
there's a and what are they in the
opposite which is you know aristocratic
uh monarchical england uh in that place
or in europe there's fixed classes and
they're huge numbers of poor people
that's sort of a symbol of a
unrepublican government
and so even though there are poor people
in america americans like to sort of
think that it's it's very small and that
people are temporarily poor and then
just come these waves of of poor people
uh from europe and they begin to fill
things we now start to call slums and
there's this kind of calculus that says
these people are
uh
artificially you know jacking up the
poverty rate in america which is a
direct threat to our to our way of being
so the irish born in new york city let's
look at the statistic in the 1850s 64
of the people that ended up in the poor
house are nate are born in ireland and
so that's way disproportionate to their
percentage in the population you also
probably noticed on this this
teeter-tottering boat it says poor house
from galway right it's a part of ireland
saying we're literally importing
unwisely importing uh poverty to this
republic
and here's an expression of this
idea that america just doesn't do
poverty right that's not part of our
political social makeup we as a people
americans are intolerant of ragged
garments and empty punches we are people
who have had no experience in physical
tribulation as a consequence the ilk
clad destitute irishman is repulsive to
our habits and our tastes we confound or
we associate ill clothing and
destitution with ignorance and vice or
unrepublican uh characteristics that's
from the christian examiner now take a
look at this image here this is also one
of the images you have in front of you
this is kind of a classic image of the
irish both male and female
what's the uh
we can assume they're poor because they
live in a shack you know it's very
but what else is
what's the what's the nature
it was looks like an
animal
in the phase kind of like almost like an
egg like i mean that's the way mid 19th
century you would be able to spot that
in a second you know in a political
cartoon or a poster you better say
that's an irishman because that's the
way they look or the way they're shown
right so this is a very much the typical
way in which he's shown um what else do
we know about him keenan without even
really knowing i didn't give you the
caption or anything um the man is
sitting down which is i don't know if
that's supposed to signify ladies like
just irish laziness yeah he's not only
poor but he's he's what he's not trying
to improve
yeah you know which is again runs
counter to that kind of bootstraps uh
political culture that we have you got
to pull yourself off out of poverty
uh he's got a bottle by his feet and a
very good he has a club underneath his
arm so two tropes right drunkenness and
violence are definitely like
significant features of the irish
stereotype and they're both shown right
there so he's not only poor uh these are
associated vices that he's a drinker uh
which may explain why he's poor uh and
he's also
ready at a drop of a hat to wield his
club and to get into a scrape um and
what about his attitude you know about
i mean we
most people tend to associate poverty
with uh with misery what's the
what's his that his
um
almost looks like content i mean
necessarily incredibly happy but he
doesn't really seem to care yeah looks
looks
yeah he looks
uh as you say content uh not upset about
his circumstances and obviously not
saying what do i have to do to get out
of these circumstances so to the to the
american viewer this is a very un
unrepublican un-american approach to
poverty you know you're supposed to be
desperate you know very embarrassed and
ashamed that you're in poverty and work
doing everything in your power uh to get
out of it but this case they seem to be
uh quite content with their with their
circumstances and again just to show you
how this idea carries forward this is an
image from 1896 uh showing uncle sam at
the gates of america and he's holding
his nose and the immigrant here is sort
of a composite eastern european you know
little little bit jewish a little bit
slavic a little bit
italian who knows what kind of a
composite immigrant and he's labeled
he's carrying a bag labeled disease he's
carrying a bag labeled poverty uh in
sabbath desecration he's got a keg on
his back so that means he's not only a
drinker but he's drinking on the sabbath
and uncle sam is trying to um trying to
stop him so these kind of i associations
are not exclusively attributed to the
irish they're they're they're you reused
depending on which group is coming all
right he had a bad label disease disease
is another uh crucial component
all right if you look at the
medical records public institution
records public hospital records in the
mid 19th century these things are also
being invented along with public schools
and you see that the irish form a huge
you know great disproportionate amount
of the patients
in the hospital this is bellevue
hospital the public hospital in new york
and it shows that 85 percent of the
foreign-born
admissions
are irish born so just almost everybody
in that poor hospital hospital for the
public the poor are irish born in the
1850s so there's this clear association
uh with disease poverty and so on here's
a pretty vivid image of from the 1880s
showing you know the grim reaper on the
bottle of a ship and that's arriving at
the tip of manhattan island which at
that time was where immigrants
landed before um
ellis island opened a few years later
and oh and i the uh
belt of this angel of death says cholera
right uh epidemic of 1849 killed 4 000
people in america principally in cities
like new orleans boston new york and
over almost half of them were irish born
so it's it's an
association with um with immigrants and
particularly with the irish and nobody
says well they they're beset by cholera
because they live in terrible housing
and terrible conditions and so forth
people just said they're filthy people
right and they they essentially bring
this upon themselves this is a immigrant
hospital prior to the days of ellis
island uh new york landed people at the
tip of manhattan island in the 1850s and
they also had a hospital there because
that's obviously one of those things
that they're concerned about is
sick immigrants that are coming in and
in staten island where this hospital was
built out in new york harbor uh a mob
showed up and destroyed the hospital
because they were
so
afraid that the spread of disease was
going to be you know greatly increased
by the presence of this hospital full of
sick
sick immigrants
and here's another one just to show the
connection this is a an anti-chinese
cartoon from san francisco in the 1880s
showing parts of san francisco
especially chinatown and leprosy and
small part you know these ghosts or
these demons are labeled leprosy
smallpox and other diseases so this this
association of immigration and disease
is very very um
very very tight
all right nativism and crime
and a lot of these overlap by the way
where you find poverty you often find
high rates of crime
nativism and crime in new york city uh
which again we keep using new york but
it's a great representation of the irish
experience 55 of those arrested in the
1850s were irish born which again you
could probably tack on another 25 20 25
if you included
irish americans
35 of the prostitutes arrested in 1858
uh were irish born so
wherever you turned you found uh irish
offenders sometimes it's petty thieves
or it's drunk and disorderly sometimes
it's it's much more serious uh stuff
and
this is a quotation about the irish from
the 1880s
by a judge who said there's a class i
was about to say a majority of the
population of new york and brooklyn to
whom the rearing of two children means
inver inevitably a boy for the
penitentiary and a girl for the brothel
so you know very blunt language saying
whenever the irish have a kid it's
either a prostitute
or a future criminal
and if you look at this image this is
from the 18th early 1870s and it shows
prisoners lining up
or i guess they're out getting out of
this
this wagon
the wagon known as
not that anybody has any personal
experience with this
well what do we call a you know a police
van
wagon right and uh because why where's
that it comes from the 1850s the the
term
the name patrick i believe yeah it's a
nickname nickname sometimes pejorative
sometimes affectionate um
but why would they call this
a paddy wagon
because they're mostly filled with
irishmen yeah so the back of it is full
of irishmen we just saw the stats it's
also possible and this is sort of an
unknown uh origin of this term it's also
possible that it refers to the fact that
a very large percentage uh of the people
driving that van uh were irishmen
wearing blue uniforms right because by
1850 the 1850s more than a quarter of
the new york city police department
is irish born so it could mean that it's
they're they're showing up as criminals
it could be that they are increasingly
members of law enforcement or both the
paddy wagon is born in that period
all right
other groups have certain kinds of
criminal attributions uh given to them
so the sinister chinese uh villain uh
emerges in the uh 1870s 1880s and
becomes the you know the part of popular
fiction and dime novels you see a kind
of a classic example of this
uh here
here's a an image from 1909 called the
fool pied piper and it shows eastern
european immigrants jews italians greeks
and so forth
coming to america as rats i mean it's
pretty blunt right in the in the real
pied piper story the pied piper plays
his pipe and the rats go out to sea and
they drown this is the fool pied piper
uncle sam not knowing any better and
he's leading the rats and vermin and
they're labeled things like thief and
bandit and anarchist and they're going
as you can see in the in the background
off to america
and notice the reaction the european
officials on the shore there jumping for
joy that america is taking all the all
the worst of european society they're
literally coming out of the sewers and
coming out of the jails so this idea of
criminality is deeply deeply embedded
all right nativism and disorder this is
a dimension of criminality basically
rioting
writing becomes a huge problem in the
mid 19th century uh in most american
cities you know we know that rioting
goes back into the colonial period they
think about the 1760s the stamp act riot
and so forth but those rights usually
were more uh demonstration riots they
were sort of shows of anger and there
was a lot of kind of pageantry and and
uh
role-playing where they'd burn an effigy
of the governor they'd break a few
things in the mid-19th century riots
become incredibly violent and deadly
people begin to die in these riots uh as
a result of clashes of armed people
this is the dead rabbits riot of 1857
which was partially as we've talked
about before featured in the movie uh
gangs of new york
um here's an expression
from a new york city merchant in the
1840s sort of talking about this
characteristic of the irish right the
vice and drunkenness among the lower
lowering laboring classes has grown
growing to fight full excess and the
multitudes of low irish catholics
restricted by poverty in their own
country run riot in this as long as we
are overwhelmed with irish immigrants so
long will the evil abound so he said
it's deeply embedded in the irish nature
to be riotous to be uh uncontrolled
which again is an opposite idea of a
republican citizen right republican
citizens rational self is self-control
that's how they get ahead not the
irishman
and here's another thomas nas cartoon
from
the 1870s showing a
a scene
greatly exaggerated there was a fracas
at a st patrick's day parade at kind of
an intersection where the parade kind of
ran into some some traffic and some
scuffling ensued but nast blows it up
into this full-on hibernian riot
and if you look closely you can see i
think i've even got a little close up
there yeah i mean notice the way he
draws the irish is these really savage
beasts who are clubbing and beating
bystanders uh and policemen
and it was double you know nasa had the
double delight of the fact that it was
on saint patrick's day that this
happened so he's basically saying you
know what what more could you possibly
expect
all right any questions at this point
all right there's more right nativism i
tell you it's it's multi-dimensional
there's a lot to it so nativism and
labor and this is one that will clearly
sound familiar uh to our modern ears
which is the idea that native that
immigrants steal jobs or lower wages you
can see this in this poster
from the 1850s natives of the soil
arouse
uh and basically saying shall american
labor be protected right americans are
being threatened by the influx of cheap
labor uh from abroad they either take
our jobs outright or they work for less
and you know the
wages of bricklayers and teamsters and
things uh begin to decline
and this is one for the american party
for the know-nothings this was probably
number two to uh anti-catholicism
all right and you can see this this
statement by the american association
for the condition of the poor
for the improvement of the condition of
the poor that basically lays this out
saying that increased immigration from
europe has had a negative impact on the
laboring mechanic classes of new york
city
needy foreigners accustomed to live upon
less than our own countrymen are enabled
to produce articles cheaper and work for
lower wages
and the solution restrict immigration
all right now what about this one this
is there's no nothing more intimately
associated with the irish
uh in this question of labor then the
the
phrase no irish need apply uh people use
it sort of jokingly now sometimes you
hear it as a nina sign no irish need
apply
and it has a really powerful
place in irish-american historical
memory you know that it's if you were to
it's like a various ethnic uh groups do
this you have sort of
phrases that kind of that capture a big
idea so the big idea is when we came to
this country in great numbers americans
hated us and discriminated against us
and made our our our
our
adjustment to america all the more
difficult right it was going to be
difficult anyway because we were poor uh
and didn't have skills and so forth and
it was sort of doubled upon us because
we uh
we were discriminated against they shut
us out of lucrative or decent jobs well
the interesting thing is most people
associate this when you sometimes hear
people talk about it they say yeah when
irishmen showed up at factories they saw
the no irish need apply sign when they
went to you know coal mines they saw no
irish need apply they went to
waterfronts they saw no irish need apply
and there's been a lot of historical
research done
uh in which historians have been looking
for the you know the evidence of this
this is what we do right we can't just
take tradition and accept it as at face
value and what's happened is uh
very little evidence of that sort exists
there are no signs there are fake
vintage signs that people have but
they're actually you know printed in the
20th century as almost like novelties
so
irish men
don't at least as far as we know tend
not to face at least these actual signs
it's not to say they aren't
discriminated against
so who are the ones who bear the brunt
of no irish need apply and where can you
find in the historical record the this
repeated repeated repeated uh phrase no
irish need apply it's in classified ads
for irish women
irish domestic servants
or domestic servants that they in which
they say no irish need apply and you can
see this ideal or this idea embodied in
this image it's also an image you have
in front of you
so
we see we've already covered this in
some respects right we we can see who's
the irish woman very clearly she's the
one who looks like an ape
uh to fit that ideal
she also has orange shamrocks on her
dress just in case you didn't get the
idea but what's going on here what do we
see dan what's the
one of the things that you notice i mean
there's quite a bit of detail
the like american woman is kind of like
all their hands kind of right and what's
wrong with that like why is that
i mean it's like kind of evoking like
fear yeah and she's the employer right
she's the one supposed to be the boss
this is her house her kitchen and she's
cowering in front of this you know
gorilla
like figure
which is a complete opposite of how it
should be right the help should be
submissive and meek before the employer
so that's one thing that's wrong and
this is a this is the female version of
the riotous irishman right the that
she's rioting essentially in the kitchen
and we can see that because there's a
broken dish on the ground um what else
what's another
problem
with the bridget which is the nickname
that or a biddy but the irish bridge in
fact i should have said that you know
you can tell who's the irish woman but
you can also you also know her name even
though you don't know her name that she
would be called a bridget
uh just like the men would be called
paddys but what's what else
what about the execution of her duties
she's very uh uncooperative
uncooperative and what about tonight's
dinner
it's like a mess yeah it's a mess i mean
something's boiling over if you look
closely in the oven something's burning
and this is the other association
america is basically saying
we need servants we're becoming a middle
class society middle class people before
the invention of vacuum cleaners and
washing machines need servants so they
begin hiring but the only the great
majority of people that that are showing
up to do that kind of work are irish
women and there's this great big
pushback so if you read the classified
ads people say wanted protestant girl
preferred german or preferred swedish or
preferred american no irish need apply
so she is you know this this
very very unlikable figure she's you
know like amelia bedelia on steroids
she's big and hulky and she's terrible
at her job
and the big what's the
why would her brother pat probably not
face
um a no irish need apply at the
waterfront what's the difference between
her job and his job
that makes americans you know just in
terms of um well it doesn't really
matter if he
is like temperamental and things at his
job because i mean if you're doing
something like a manual labor job like
if you're working on the docs right no
one's really going to care
whereas if you're working in somebody's
house they're going to obviously get
upset if you're
wrecking their house and not doing a job
and and and also that you're going to be
dealing with children and with and with
the adults so yeah the sanctity of the
american home this whole ideal of
domesticity is developing in middle
class american culture the home is
supposed to be clean and wholesome and
peaceful above all and here comes this
you know this one woman wrecking crew
who's going to do a terrible job and you
know who knows what
with the children and with the with the
house this is uh
it's a it's a conundrum and if you just
if you go into a historical database and
type in
servant problem you'll get hundreds and
hundreds of articles in newspapers that
have that in the headline the servant
problem by which they mean we need lots
of servants and the only ones we can
seem to get are these women from uh from
ireland here's the uh the ad from from a
text from an ad wanted an english or
american woman that understands cooking
to assist in the work generally have
wished also a girl to do chamber work
none need apply without recommendation
from their last place irish people
capital letters in case you didn't get
the message need not apply and goes on
from there right so that and this is
where you do find the evidence so it's
really aimed at bridget less so than uh
that pack because who cares about the
behavior as aden was saying of an
irishman on the dock or in the coal
mines as long as he's doing his job
here's a later one this is a again not
an irish image this is an image of sort
of that swore the
amalgam of eastern european southern
european uh characteristics he's he's
reaching his notice his little plume
there says popper labor poor labor and
he's reaching in and taking the food
right off the table of the american-born
working man and the title is you know
the inevitable result to the american
work workmen of indiscriminate
immigration that we need to control our
immigration so that jobs and wages
are preserved here's one that aimed at
the chinese in the same time period
showing a chinese immigrant with 10 arms
doing all these different jobs and the
young american men just kind of kicking
around on the right hand side because
presumably uh they're unemployed
what shall we do with our boys from 1882
all right there's more nativism and race
you've probably already picked up on
this but some of these images of the
irish as as beasts uh is not just
somebody being mean it's somebody
dipping into the emerging idea of racial
uh ideas and racial um categories and so
forth and so if you take a look at two
images close up that we've already seen
we see that this this is again not just
to be mean to the irish but it's to say
these people are indeed lower
on the scale of humanity they belong to
a lower
race that is not too far from the baboon
as depicted here all right
george templeton strong who was a great
civic leader and merchant in new york in
the mid 19th century kept a big diary or
a regular diary just a gold mine of
resources for historians and he wrote a
lot about the irish almost always in
horror at their alien ways and behavior
and he said our celtic fellow citizens
are almost as remote from us in
temperament and constitution as the
chinese and again the chinese are way
they're the furthest out on the spectrum
of
acceptability
here's an image from an 1860s
essentially a physiology textbook it's a
a book that is
designed it's called physiognomy the new
physiognomy 1866 and uh you can see that
it's almost like that uh you see a lot
of similarity between this and that uh
servant picture right you've got the
beautiful composed intelligent um
american-born woman and she actually or
in this case florence nightingale you
know a
famous famous figure who's a real person
and if you look closely what's the name
of the woman on the on the far right she
looks ape-like she looks dirty she looks
dumb and her name is bridget mcbruiser
right and i just have to tell you there
is nobody named there's no real person
named bridget mcbruiser so even in the
naming they're kind of tipping their hat
there but this is in a textbook
explaining the connection between
physiology
and personality and and intelligence and
so forth
sometimes race is is explicitly
shown in these images and in these uh
documents here you can see the irish
woman being put side by side with an
african-american woman a notice
in the age of slavery in the age of
enraging anti-black racism
how the irish are being shown here in
this case the irish woman is being shown
as much much you know lower
uh much more inferior much
less desirable less controlled less
intelligent uh than the african-american
woman beside her and the whole point of
the cat of the of the cartoon is that
this irish woman is very upset
that she's sitting next to a black woman
when in fact the black woman is much
more intelligent much more
middle class than she is or probably
ever will be
there's another image when thomas nast
uh where he's it's again it's political
commentary during the era of
reconstruction and he's basically saying
there's a problem in the south that
blacks have been given the right to vote
and there's a problem in the north that
everybody who's white and a citizen can
vote including uh these legions of
irishmen
so it's a tapping into two kinds of
racial ideas there
so race becomes and race will come and
become increasing as race becomes more
and i'm putting up my fingers scientific
uh
in the late 19th early 20th century and
eventually ideas like eugenics develop
race and immigration the racial
component of natives and becomes more
pronounced
all right nativism and politics uh
because all of these people as thomas
nast uh indicates
uh all the men above a certain age who
are become citizens can vote and this is
a horror to a lot of people here you see
a mid-19th century image of an irishman
in this case also with the german the
irishman's in a whiskey barrel the
germans in a lager beer barrel and
they're running away with a ballot box
they are literally hijacking democracy
the idea is being connoted here is these
are not intelligent republican citizens
these are who think about the issues
who take great care in casting their
vote these are people that are just
winning elections because there's so
many of them and they're turning it into
a corrupt spoils system
harper's weekly in the article that we
read last night one of its indictments
of the irish in 1860 among many was that
the system of universal suffrage in
large cities has fallen into discredit
through the incapacity of the irish
self-government that they are they're
filling our jails they're filling our
hospitals they're filling our slums and
they're also pulling down the sacredness
of our democracy
and so there's nothing another classic
image of the irish in the late 19th mid
and late 19th century is this political
boss this this guy who's subverting
democracy corralling votes um using the
poor immigrant vote to his advantage to
gain the system and then to you know
enrich himself and his friends through
corruption so you've got the the boodle
boodles a great old great 19th century
term just means like you know uh
a brutal
boss who's got his thumb
on democracy
and his boot on the taxpayer and on the
right-hand side
tammany hall the most famous irish run
political machine has its boot on city
hall and that's the mayor of new york
shining the shoes of tammany so it's
it's a very very powerful association
with in this case very much the irish no
one's really complaining about german
political power or italian political
power at least not yet
all right we're getting close to the end
of this list nativism and radicalism
well this becomes an important point
especially as cities develop and we
already talked about the incidence of
rioting and strikes as well
as the 19th century unfolds the
industrial revolution gets more and more
advanced in the size of factories and so
forth wage work becomes more common
strikes become a big feature of american
society and a lot of americans say don't
say oh people are striking and and
striking strikes become violent
sometimes because
people aren't being paid enough they say
people are rioting because that's in
their nature these are foreigners who
come and don't understand our ways and
they're predisposed to rioting so in
1885 josiah strong who wrote these words
said the city has become a menace to our
civilization it is a peculiar attraction
for the immigrant here is heap the
social dynamite which is just a great
phrase here roughs gamblers thieves
robbers lawless and desperate men of all
sorts congregate many who are ready on
any pretext to raise riots for the
purpose of destruction and plunder so
he's saying these riots are attributed
to immigrants with riotous natures and
riotous political ideologies like
socialism
and anarchism and here you see the irish
kind of lumped in with with a whole
variety of groups this is uh colombia
you know lady liberty stopping these
unwanted immigrants uh in the 1880s and
they're they are not a pleasant looking
group and you see anarchists and
socialists and communists coming in from
eastern europe and in the lower right uh
you see
your irishman because and notice what
he's carrying he's carrying a bag label
labeled dynamite and that's because
irish immigrants
irish americans were deeply involved in
the irish nationalist movement the
effort to free ireland in the 1880s and
that does involve a certain level of
violence and a certain level of raising
money
for um for essentially terrorism uh
which is our next yeah
does black hands mean i've seen that on
a couple of the questions black hand has
two has two meanings it's a it's a
nickname for the mafia it also refers to
eastern european uh radicals uh
anarchists and so forth so um you see it
kind of used interchangeably in these
kind of cartoons
founded in new york city in the 1850s
and it was example of irish
yep the irish revolutionary brotherhood
and they make no bones about it they say
our goal as americans as irish
immigrants and irish americans is to
raise money
to foment an armed insurrection in
ireland that will throw the british
colonial rule off and that involves
assassinations if need be that involves
blowing up british ships and so forth
would as need be so that's the where the
association of irish and both radicalism
and uh terrorism here's an image from
the foot of manhattan island uncle sam
is watching all these pretty scary
looking immigrants landing and at his
feet is a document that says the mafia
in new orleans reference to italians
anarchists in chicago so this is just
after the haymarket bombing um so
referring to germans and then socialists
in new york means just radicals galore
uh new york is sort of the capital of
socialist america
another one uncle sam here cowering and
saying you know trying to protect
america american institutions and from
riff raff immigration and all these
little faces are labeled anarchists and
socialist and and communists and so
forth um
high tide of immigration on a national
menace it's in 1903. and did we leave
anything out an explicit statement about
terrorism i mentioned terrorism but
let's talk about this in particular um
in the 1880s we think of terrorism as a
relatively new thing and the association
of immigrants
from certain places and terrorism is a
new thing but it's not it goes back to
the least of the
1870s 1880s when the irish are raising
this money and this is a parody of an
irish nationalist meeting meeting in
agitation hall and they're the they're
requiring all these agitators to check
their bombs at the door um before they
go into the meeting
um and this very movement in the 18
early 1880s the fenians it's a nickname
for some of these irish nationalists
they uh raised a lot of money and they
used that money for different purposes
but one of the things they did was they
raised money to build a submarine and
they got this guy john holland came from
ireland who was a trained engineer and
and uh architect and he designed a
functioning
sub submarine in new york harbor one of
the first functioning submarines in
america and the idea behind it was
called the fenian ram and it was going
to sink british ships it never got
beyond the test phase
before it never you know never was put
into action but uh john holland went on
to become a really important figure in
the american navy and really the father
of the american
submarine program
okay um well all of this
leads to and we should
see how we're doing on
on time we're getting close all of this
leads to this kind of amalgam of
ideas about the threat posed by
immigration uh both the irish but with
all these other groups there's a lot of
agitation about
immigration in the 1840s and 1850s 1870s
1880s and into the early 20th century
and eventually organizations begin to
emerge that you know like the no nothing
sort of successors of the old of the
know-nothings that are
committed to restricting uh immigration
if not cutting it off uh altogether and
they're unsuccessful to a large degree
because
for one thing american business
interests love immigration because it
means just endless streams of cheap uh
labor so they don't want you if you're
in the steel you know own steel mills in
pittsburgh you don't want immigration
cut off because that's you know
tremendous source of uh inexpensive
labor
and also ethnic groups you know once
ethnic groups get a foothold here they
plan to bring lots of their family over
so they also politically oppose
immigration restriction because they
don't want to see the door shut uh at
least on their people
but eventually world war one and some of
the you know the great strike waves
after world war one
and just rising continuing rising
concerns about uh the impact of heavy
immigration on american society leads to
uh the restriction movement uh the
success of the restriction movement 1921
and then again in 1924
laws are passed that greatly reduce uh
the amount of immigrants coming to the
country from nearly a million a year
sometimes more than a million year down
to just about 150 000 so the the flow is
not completely staunch but it's greatly
greatly reduced
as a result of this and it's going to
stay that way
with some exceptions all the way into
the 1960s at which point we reopen our
redesign our immigration program and
allow for much freer uh flow of people
to come in but there's that 40-year
period of
of restriction which is sort of the
exception to the american
tradition
all right we have about five minutes
left
does anybody have
any questions
you think about um
these ideas about the the way these
things are are ranked i mean i've
already said that uh immigration and
relig you know anti-catholicism was was
crucial um and labor but anybody have
any other questions or questions about
the documents
from last night
all right well if
if we've maxed out on
nativism for the day i will uh
call it a day and say we'll see you
on friday
all right
i